hello everyone welcome to another
q a about history of science and
technology
i am not yet back in my natural habitat
i will be next week
um
so
uh
here we are well let's see i have a
bunch of questions that came in here
um
wow there's a question about
combinatory logic and statistical
mechanics
well actually as it happens i've been
making quite a study recently the
history of statistical mechanics
and thermodynamics
and
maybe i could describe a little bit
about that
so i mean the the big story
that led to statistical mechanics the
sort of the aggregate theory of lots of
molecules and other things bouncing
around
the big thing that led to that was
thermodynamics the study of kind of the
dynamics of heat
and i think the thing that really drove
that was in the 1700s with the invention
of steam engines which had had
precursors even back to antiquity but
the the full steam engine uh
that term came into existence in the mid
1700s um that was a story of you take
heat
and you make useful mechanical work from
the heat
by having
the you know the steam expand and push
pistons and things like this to make
mechanical work
and i think people like james watt and
so on were concerned about questions
like how would you make a steam engine
more efficient what would be the uh
you know is that is that a possible
thing to do and maybe one possibility
would be can you have something we just
take a bunch of heat
and you convert that heat into useful
mechanical work just have something
that's hot
and
that's all you have
can you turn that into useful mechanical
work
now people had tried to do that they
tried to make a um
that eventually got the name of a
perpetual motion machine of the second
kind
um
let me explain a couple of things so
so
there's a big question about what is
heat
what a gas is made of what happens when
you heat up a gas and it expands for
example
um in the 1600s people already started
talking about the idea that um gases
might be made of discrete atoms of some
kind bouncing around for some reason
which i need to track down by the 1700s
that theory had really gone out of favor
and there was instead the idea that heat
was some kind of fluid a phlogiston
fluid that would suffuse things and be
the thing that contributed uh to heat
and um
the thing that
um uh
and and so
that was that was the thing that really
dominated the 1700s and until the
mid-1800s there was still this kind of
logistic theory of heat
and the idea that heat was a kind of
motion of discrete underlying molecules
that was an idea that really didn't come
in seriously again until the mid-1800s
and i think the um
there started to be these questions
about okay how would we make a really
efficient steam engine well when you
have the floor just on theory of heat we
have all kinds of weird things that you
think about about making an efficient
steam engine and one of the things that
was true was that there was clearly a
notion of mechanical work
and energy expenditure and things like
that that existed as you move material
things you know
levers and pistons and wheels and so
when you move those things around that's
clearly a form of energy usage
mechanical work etc uh you know moving a
thing through moving a force through it
through a particular distance that's
sort of almost a quintessential
definition of energy
so
this question of of uh what was the
relationship between heat and mechanical
energy was the thing that was sort of a
big thing in the early 1800s and so on
very confused uh a guy called maya
was i think the person person who first
really suggested that maybe heat is a
form of energy and maybe there's even a
conservation of overall energy that you
can have
energy in the form of heat molecules
individually bouncing around or in the
form of mechanical work sort of
systematic motion but they're all just
kinds of energy
and that idea
became
called the first principle or the first
law of thermodynamics the law of energy
conservation that says that you can have
energy in the form of heat you can have
energy in the form of mechanical work
you're just trading off these energies
you can't get sort of energy from
nothing
and so one of the questions was could
you have a perpetual motion machine of
the first kind that violated the first
stellar thermodynamics and just
generated energy from nothing was the
first possibility the second thing was
what could you really do with heat to
what extent could you take the energy
that is in the form of heat and organize
it into mechanical work that would push
pistons and things like this
and and that
led to a set of principles in the 18
well the
first first thing i suppose that
happened was the work of sadika no
in the 1820s
not widely known at the time although
within a few decades
became more widely known
khano
his interest was how would you make a
more efficient steam engine
how in general would you make a more
efficient heat engine
and i think i suppose the big thing that
he did was to have this idea that you
could talk about an idealized heat
engine you didn't need to be
specifically talking about the
engineering of steam and iron and things
like this that you could have a
theoretical abstracted heat engine and
discuss its efficiency
and
he kind of suggested the idea that the
real way to make a heat engine was to
have a hot reservoir and a cold
reservoir that you were dealing with the
difference of of temperatures between
two different things by the way i should
say that the idea of temperature is
something you can measure and that
different kinds of thermometers would
measure the same temperature from
something that was an idea that had
started i think in the 1600s that there
was a definite notion of temperature and
that although you might have different
ways of measuring it with an alcohol
thermometer or mercury thermometer or
whatever else you're measuring the
expansion of alcohol when you increase
the temperature or expansion of mercury
when you increase the temperature um and
nowadays it will be an electronic device
where you're measuring the uh the
increasing number of charge carriers
that get promoted to the conduction band
or something when the temperature goes
up but that's a thing of modern times
thermoelectric kinds of effects um
back in back in those times it was
mostly expansion of liquids and things
it was used to measure temperature but
the idea was these different temperature
measuring
methods would agree it wouldn't be the
case that oh if you've measured an iron
bar a mercury thermometer would say it
was this an alcohol thermometer would
say it was that and if you measured a uh
um you know the air you get a different
relative result from mercury and um
and alcohol no you got the same result
there was a definite notion of
temperature independent of the measuring
device that you could that you could get
and so what kano said was well it seemed
like the efficiency of a heat engine
would depend on the difference in
temperature between the hot part of the
heat engine the cold part of the heat
engine that the story was really a
motion of heat from the hot part to the
cold part it was some kind of way of
making that heat systematic by somehow
taking as we would now understand it
taking all those microscopic motions of
molecules and saying there's a place
where they're all very hot over here and
they're all running around very fast
there's a place where they're cold here
if you connect those two together there
will be a systematic motion of molecules
that will go from the hot side to the
cold side
and but uh to carnot it was kind of the
idea of idealizing the operation of a
heat engine not in terms of this
particulars of steam and so on but just
in terms of a a a high temperature part
and a low temperature part it's kind of
amusing to read carnot's works because
he begins with this giant
um
uh it's i think his piece is called on
the motive power of heat
at least in english it was written in
french originally um and uh
the um it really begins with a giant
pitch for the importance of steam
engines and it's like you no longer have
to use air currents that's windmills or
animal power that's donkeys and things
to get energy you can use a steam engine
and a steam engine will be portable and
he quotes things like the fact that uh
in in england he says that uh sort of
this critical thing occurred that coal
mining had become uneconomical because
it was too difficult to raise the coal
and so on from the mines but now there
are steam engines and it's ten times
more efficient to to mine things kind of
a
lesson for modern times that if you uh
you know if
there's there's oil in the ground but it
can take more and more effort and be
more and more expensive to mine it out
and it depends on whether it's
worthwhile but that was a case where the
steam engine um was uh was the thing
that really apparently made sort of coal
mining practical again in england and
probably you know probably eventually
led to the industrial revolution and all
kinds of things like that um in england
in any case the um
uh the the question of of um so going
back to cono had done this idea of
thermodynamics this idea of motion
uh and motion of heat and its
relationship to mechanical work and this
idea of the need to have a hot reservoir
and a cold reservoir and what people
really wanted was if you just had the
hot reservoir you just had something
that was hot
could you derive mechanical work from
that and that became this question of
could you make a perpetual motion
machine of the second kind
and the second kind related to violating
the second principle the second the the
um uh the second law of thermodynamics
and that second law of thermodynamics
came in in different forms a person
called clausius
in 1850s um was a person who was sort of
key to to to identifying ways to state
this but it would be things like we just
observe that heat doesn't spontaneously
go from a colder body to a hotter body
if you have something that's hot and
something that's cold yes the hot thing
can make the cold thing hotter but the
cold thing can't make the hot thing
hotter
it always the heat always flows from the
hot side to the cold side so to speak so
that was one kind of statement of the um
of the second law of thermodynamics
um
another
uh another
statement let's see um
the uh there are varieties kind of
related statements of the second law
about um
uh the um
um
the question of of under what
circumstances yes the other the other
common statement is that you can't make
a perpetual motion machine of the second
kind that it's not possible to derive
mechanical work purely from a single hot
thing without this hot coal difference
so to speak
in any case between
the statement of the first law energy
conservation and the statement of the
second law which seemed like it was the
same kind of thing
that was the 1860s
and then uh william thompson later lord
kelvin got into the act with his
statements of the second law
and then uh james clerk maxwell got
involved with a very nice uh sort of
clear approach to um to talking about
heat and temperature and so on now at
the time nobody knew yet that molecules
were a real thing they kind of realized
that the phlogiston theory wasn't making
it and that there had to be some kind of
molecular theory of heat but it wasn't
really fully established what that would
be and nobody knew like what the shapes
of molecules were and so if you look at
the works of james maxwell james scott
maxwell um a lot of what he talks about
is actual molecular collisions and he's
studying the classical mechanics
classical mechanics was kind of a big
field at the time of if you have
spherical molecules and they collide
he's got all these diagrams of force
vectors and so on about how the
collisions work all those kinds of
things what really happens then he
considers the case what if the molecules
were the shapes of uh with sort of
triangular prisms and other and poly
polygonal molecules polyhedral molecules
things like that what would happen
in in these collisions
and so one of the things that maxwell
does is to derive the distribution of
energies that you would expect in these
collisions and actually turns out it's a
very general result i i was just playing
with this just yesterday and it's uh
it's something where it's actually you
need very few assumptions to derive this
as soon as you have something where you
imagine that pairs of things collide
and they exchange some energy and then
they go out again and the total energy
of the incoming particles is the same as
the total energy of the outcoming
particles it's just redistributed
between the particles that fact alone
together with a minimal degree of
randomness in how those collisions
happens is sufficient to give you a very
specific distribution the probability
that you get a molecule of energy e
falls off exponentially with e it's the
so-called maxwell boltzmann distribution
that was derived by maxwell while the
full maxwell boltzmann distribution has
a factor for the um we're just counting
vectors the number of vectors of a given
length so it's a v squared e to the
minus mv squared uh type formula
but um
the thing that
um uh
has um
uh so so
by the 1860s there's kind of this idea
of oh
there's um
there's this underlying molecular
structure
there's the second law of thermodynamics
that tells you what you can kind of do
with all these random molecules bouncing
around
then the next piece was this question
about equilibrium this question about
when would a process be an equilibrium
in the sense that its properties would
no longer be spontaneously changing at
least its aggregate properties would no
longer be spontaneously changing so for
example if you have a gas
rushing from one container out into the
vacuum that's not equilibrium until the
gas has kind of just sort of settled
itself into the into the into the vacuum
or whatever um and so that was sort of
the question of when when you are out of
equilibrium what is the tendency of what
happens and what was realized was that
the second law of thermodynamics this
law that talks about the overall
features of heat and temperature and so
on really has the implication that
what has to happen is that things get
more random you can't so for example
looked at in terms of molecules
mechanical work you have a bar of stuff
and it's got a bunch of molecules in it
when you move that bar all the molecules
are moving in the same direction
when you
simply heat up that bar all the
molecules are running around they could
be running around very fast but they're
running around in random directions
and so the second law
basically was understood to be
things tend to go from systematic to
random there tends to be a a progression
of things getting more random
now
then into the scene comes uh ludwig
boltzmann
who then tries to derive
the um the second law i should i should
mention another important piece
uh clausius
had defined this quantity called entropy
so energy was this quantity people like
maya had had said entropies of energy is
a thing and it's conserved and the
question then was well is that all there
is that determines how systems work is
the conservation of energy and what uh
clausius said was no there's actually
another thing we'll call it entropy and
he he had kind of a entropy he wanted
the name to sound a bit like energy but
to be about trope transformations the
greek word for transformation tropez um
that was went into entropy so it was
about kind of um transformations of
things and the idea was that it would
describe the way in which things could
transform
and so what what happened was
uh clausius defined the entropy to the b
well in sort of mathy notation dq over t
q is the is the heat
dq will be the difference of the heat
and t is the temperature so entropy is
basically the
uh as you as you change the the plot
change
the character you you change a thing
you're adding heats to a thing but
you're asking at what temperature is
that heat going in so this is saying as
you change the heat
divided by the temperature what what
result does that give you
and he defined that as being the entropy
and he said that the second law was the
law that that entropy quantity always
increases in a closed system
that if you just have a system where
there is um uh where where things are
just sort of rattling around there's no
effect from the outside that the change
of of of uh
um
let's see the the um
i'm getting myself confused because it's
the adiabatic case is the case where
there's no heat coming from from the
outside um and uh
uh isothermal would mean there's no
temperature change but i guess what's
happening here
is um
you have a a change of the entropy
um
that is associated with
this this sort of progressive change of
both heat content and temperature
okay so then the next big question was
well what
what is this entropy object you know is
there some other interpretation of it
perhaps in terms of molecules
the um
the big thing that boltzmann
suggested
was this formula which was eventually on
on boltzmann's tombstone
uh what he wrote as s equals k log w
later it was more often written s equals
k log capital omega um what it was was
the entropy is equal to some constant
now called boltzmann's constant times
the logarithm of the number of states in
the system so a very weird sort of
connection between microscopic counting
of states in the system
and
uh and the entropy quantity but why is
something like that right i think at the
time it was much less clear although
when i was just looking at a paper of
boltzmann's yesterday and boltzmann was
actually doing quite a lot of discrete
mathematics it makes sort of planck's
achievement in 1900 of understanding
black body radiation and the bulk of the
the bose einstein um distribution
instead of the planck or blank spectrum
and then later those einstein statistics
makes that a little less impressive
because boltzmann was really already
doing this thing where he says let's
consider something where there are just
seven possible boxes and each one has an
integer number of things in it
and he was doing that
as a um as a way to kind of uh
you know make real this counting of
states this s equals k logo omega kind
of thing
but so why should entropy defined as
this heat to temperature ratio have
anything to do with the counting of the
number of states well first thing to
realize is if you've got n boxes sort of
n places where you can put energy let's
say
n particles whatever else n degrees of
freedom then the number of possible
configurations of that is something like
2 to the n so the logarithm gets rid of
the 2 to the n and it's just n times
some constant
so what that logarithm is doing is
saying basically how many degrees of
freedom are there so it's saying entropy
is equal to some constant times the
number of degrees of freedom
but also this heat quantity is kind of
the that heat is the sort of macroscopic
version
of how much energy is there in the
system temperature is defined to be
basically related to the average energy
per per particle and so this heat
divided by temperature thing is
essentially measuring the number of
particles or the number of degrees of
freedom and that's why there's a
connection between uh kind of the
entropy as defined by boltzmann of k log
omega and the entropy as defined by
clausius as dq over t
anyway so that was the thing boltzmann
realized in the 1860s and then boltzmann
tried to work out if you had collisions
between molecules
how would this entropy quantity now
understood microscopically how would
that entropy quantity change
and so what he was doing was then to say
the entropy is equal to if f is the
number of particles of energy e
it's f log f basically the integral of
that over energies
is the is the entropy and so then what
boltzmann figured out
is that
there is a um
uh
that
okay that that the that entropy quantity
he defined as a negative of the current
one
is something that decreases the h
function decreases the entropy increases
with time and so he worked that out by
just working out if you have collisions
of molecules and they're random
collisions of molecules
then this quantity this efflog f thing
really worked out it's just a
mathematical result that that
causes the entropy to increase in time
okay well it's a little bit weird
because
here's the big problem the other big
thing people thought about was
reversibility the fact is that the laws
of mechanics you know rigid balls
bouncing off each other they're
reversible in the sense that any process
that can go in one direction can equally
well go in the opposite direction now
little micro footnote 1964 this
phenomenon called cp violation was
discovered in particle physics in the
decays of the case 0 meson
which is a phenomenon whereby the uh it
isn't in fact the case that every
property of things is the same when time
is running forwards as when time is
running backwards but it is the case
that every process for which there is a
forward description of the process you
can reverse the description and make a
backward description of the process
though those forward and backward
descriptions aren't necessarily quite
the same it's kind of like like the
difference between symmetric
cryptography and asymmetric public key
cryptography in sort of symmetric
cryptography the encryption and
decryption are the same in public key
cryptography the thing going in the
forward direction has a different key
than the thing going in the backward
direction and so it is with cp violation
or time reversal violation that was
discovered in the early 1960s
um but that's not really a relevant
effect that doesn't affect this this
boltzmann result that entropy can be
computed to increase based on this
microscopic model okay that's very weird
because how can anything increase with
time if everything is symmetrical and
you could just reverse the time and
everything should go backwards
and in fact this is often in textbooks
but sort of my favorite not favorite
textbook quote
is you know the textbook will go through
and prove the h theorem and then say but
you could in fact reverse all the times
and then you would prove the opposite of
the h theorem and it says one one famous
textbook i think ends its chapter with
this point is offering often puzzling to
the student as it has been to people for
a hundred years but that's a different
issue
so in any case the how does this
actually happen well
people at the time of boltzmann had all
these objections to boltzmann's result
like the reversibility objection another
objection was that eventually any system
would recur that any system would
eventually repeat its behavior any
deterministic system would eventually
repeat its behavior although the time to
do so might be exponentially long
but so this reversibility objection it's
like how can you have proved that
entropy increases when your proof would
have to be able to be run in the
opposite direction and you know from a
practical point of view why do we
observe that if you smash something it's
broken little pieces and it doesn't you
can readily smash things but you can't
readily sort of have a self-assembly of
things to have all those pieces come
together again why does there seem to be
this kind of arrow of time that leads to
increasing randomness
and i think this is something i finally
understood i sort of made a big
i almost understood in the 1980s and i
think finally now do understand it and
all has to do with the question of well
there is in principle a way that you
could prepare all the molecules so
they'd all come together and make this
very orderly thing at some point in the
future but that way of preparing it is
not something that a computationally
bounded observer like us
can can execute that instead we have to
think about it as this process
of um of evolution of the system is a
is a computationally irreducible process
and so when we ask questions about
what's going on we are computationally
bounded observers we can only see
certain kinds of things and there is we
can't we can only prepare certain kinds
of states and they inevitably have these
properties of getting increasingly
random and so on
but i should explain that in in the
history of statistical mechanics another
big figure was josiah willard gibbs an
early american physicist from the 1870s
lived until the early 1900s i worked at
yale all his life
um he was
a um he really tried to sort of more
mathematicize this treatment of
statistical mechanics and introduced
this idea of ensembles the idea of
looking not just at the evolution of a
particular system but a whole collection
of possible configurations of the same
system and so many results of
statistical mechanics were quoted in
terms of these ensembles and that was
sort of the the originating idea of lots
of mathematical statistical mechanics
led to this idea of the partition
function
the partition function is something
quite uh that gets used in different
forms in quantum field theory and things
like this
uh so a sort of a a a general idea
i think there was a question of um
here about the relationship between
statistical mechanics and things like
combinators
you know the history of computation and
the history of statistical mechanics
have been very disjoint histories i mean
i think i personally have been the
person probably most involved in trying
to bring those those two traditions
together maybe there are a few other
people who were involved in the question
of the thermodynamics of computation
like john von neumann had made the
statement that
every uh computation is necessarily
dissipated necessarily turns uh sort of
mechanical work into heat this turns out
not to be true a guy uncle ralph
landauer argued this that a person
called charles bennett gave a nice
example of how this fails to be true um
other people ed fred kim was involved in
another example of this
and the basic observation is
that the way that dissipation occurs is
when when you make a choice
and then you throw away the other choice
that's when dissipation when sort of
heat is generated so for example in a
typical logic operation if you say it's
the or of two things it's like we have a
one or a zero or a zero or a one and
both of those give a one but you don't
know whether what was what was
came before that output one was a one
zero or a zero one you can no longer
reverse things you no longer have
reversibility when you don't have
reversibility it inevitably follows that
you have this kind of dissipation
process going on
and so the question is can you make
reversible logic and the answer is just
simply plainly yes and for example when
people do
quantum circuits that's all based on
reversible logic because quantum
mechanics before you make measurements
and things is a reversible mathematical
setup or it has the same
uh it's why it has unitary evolution the
unitary matrix is invertible
um
so
it uh uh there was kind of this this
attempt to mix sort of this question of
where whether whether thermodynamics
and computation mixed that way and that
was sort of one emerging thing then then
my own efforts had to do with kind of
introducing this idea of computational
irreducibility in the mid-1980s 1984 or
so um and i just found yesterday
actually i i've completely forgotten
this i have a statement at the end of a
paper i wrote in 1985 about origins of
randomness and physical systems i
basically say
whether these sort of intrinsically
random processes i say it seems likely
that these intrinsically random
processes are directly related to the
second order of thermodynamics and that
turns out to be true and i've now
figured out a lot more detail about that
um uh that that path of things
um in any case that was uh but in terms
of other connections between sort of
computation and statistical mechanics i
don't think there really have been many
um you know i think this is we're now
seeing very interesting convergence of
those things where we think about
statistical mechanics and computational
terms and we think about the lessons of
statistical mechanics of the emergence
of continuum behavior and things like
this as being relevant for other kinds
of computational processes and thereby
physical processes
okay let me see
we have a question here from brady about
who's saying wonders why i didn't
explore chess in my paper on
multi-computational games and can
discuss the history of chess ais can we
design a better game somehow and so on
um the reason i didn't
do
uh study chess was because i didn't get
around to it uh breit fellow at our
summer school this year actually did
study um chess and games in
multi-computational uh in a
multi-computational way and got some
really nice results actually um so he uh
he was able to follow up on that idea
um
well let's talk about chess chess is a
really old game
um and uh
you know played for a long time
different places
the sort of the theory of chess
i think by the late 1800s early 1900s
there were an increasing number of sort
of top chess players who sort of were
thinking theoretically about kind of the
the you know these are possible end
games with cataloging end games things
like this so far as i know 1912 was the
first time that anybody thought about
the kind of graph of a game so you know
you have a state of a game as a node and
you have that's joined to other states
of the game by by plays that you can
make and you can ask the question
how does uh the um uh how does the graph
that you form from all possible sort of
moves that you can make in the game what
is the structure of that graph what can
you say about it and so on and i think
ernst mello was the person who worked on
zamelo frankel set theory the sort of
standard axiomatic theorem used in
mathematics
uh he in his talk at the international
congress of mathematicians in 1912
had something about chess
and and game graphs
um and and he couched what he was
discussing very much in terms of set
theory because that was kind of his
brand
and was talking about kind of the
construction of these graphs
in terms of
of sets and so on but in the end uh you
know he sort of mentioned i think some
crest chess grand masters and so on in
the end it was a story of this is a way
we can think systematically about chess
in terms of graphs now the actual graph
for the full possible graph of possible
chess games is absurdly large you know
for tic-tac-toe it's about about 5 000
different configurations of the game
that can ever occur for chess it's 10 to
the 100 or something or much more than
that that can occur
and so
that was kind of the um
uh the the sort of the early
mathematicization of chess
then i would say the first time where
there had been sort of supposed chess
automata famously the mechanical turk
was in what the 1700s 1800s maybe
um
which was a very small person who was a
good chess player sitting inside a box
moving things around with magnets and
playing a chess game and that's kind of
like it's artificial artificial
intelligence where it's actually a
person inside the machine so to speak
that's doing it the the uh the
mechanical turk i think it was a turkish
person who was the um the sort of the uh
the circus provider so to speak or the
mechanical turk thing
and um that was uh uh that was that was
kind of an early sort of fake chess
automaton
um
when did real ones start being talked
about well i know that david champagnone
and alan turing who were friends at
king's college cambridge
in the 1920s
got interested in chess playing
sort of automating the game of chess and
figuring out how to make kind of a
machine to play chess i don't know how
far they really got that
um
then
uh
when people were looking at uh you know
turing and friends were were studying
kind of the um
the breaking of the enigma codes during
world war ii kind of that that notion of
you tree out all these possibilities you
look at all these possible possible
passwords effectively that started to
feel a little bit like you try out all
these possibilities in a chess game and
i think maybe that led to maybe further
discussion um from touring on on the
possibility of machines to play chess
but he never actually implemented such a
thing
so i don't know who was the first person
who um
uh
uh who actually built a chess machine
chess computer but i do know at mit
in the early 60s there was a whole lot
of activity around this
person richard greenblatt was much
involved in making sort of a chess
machine i think ed fredkin had something
to do with with sort of uh sponsoring
that i think in fact ed i think had for
a while a prize like a hundred thousand
dollar prize for the first machine that
can beat a grand master at chess um and
i think that was initiated in the early
1960s
and so there was a bunch of activity of
building essentially special purpose
machines that would play chess and which
would do effectively this treeing out a
possible possible outcomes in the game
and so the big issue was okay you're at
this at this configuration of the game
let's try and look five moves ahead and
see what possible things can happen
and uh
which of those possibilities do we like
the best and so let's pick that
particular move
um but i think that was something that
was done in hardware with kind of
special purpose some special purpose
hardware that was uh was still happening
in the that was happening let's see that
maybe i'm i'm getting myself off by a
decade or two because certainly in the
1980s
that was am i getting my
no that was happening in the 70s right
that was happening in 1970s
and then by the time i mean i certainly
knew a bunch of these people and one of
the things that
that sort of turned into is the effort
to build a list machine and these two
companies symbolics inc and and list
machining incorporated
um
the uh which had all kinds of
entanglements with my first company um
and uh
my smp system which was sort of
uh first i would say commercial sort of
computer algebra symbolic computation
system
was um
uh
well at least it became commercial um
was written in c as opposed to lisp but
those other those lisp systems were kind
of the the wannabes of that world but
their original use case had been things
like playing chess
so in any case this idea of how do you
look enough moves ahead and how do you
uh kind of um
uh
how how do you how do you sort of
optimize that process that was sort of
the big issue of chess chess machines
now you know is it ai
well you know it's very mechanical it's
very much let's just look these number
of moves ahead let's see what happens
etc etc etc um in the end
the this deep blue
uh
machine from ibm in the
1990s early 1990s i think
um
which sort of did the big pr thing of
winning
the sort of chess championships type
type games um that was very much a a
continuation of that tradition of just
you know grind the the game tree and
look enough moves ahead and see what
happens and have good assessment schemes
for figuring out kind of what
uh you know what counts as a you know
how much is a queen really worth if you
lose your queen you lose a bishop you
lose this how much is that really worth
and i think that kind of probably you
know interwove with with things that the
people who were sort of the the people
writing all the books of chess openings
and things had some sense of that and
that's probably what informed how those
programs are written
now you know what's happened more
recently for example the game of go
which is a simpler in terms of rules but
more difficult in terms of of gameplay
kind of game um that was much more
difficult to automate i remember when i
was a kid
when i was like oh 13 years old or so i
i knew the game of go and i thought it
was kind of cool because i'm not a big
game-playing person but but um i thought
it was cool because it had such simple
rules and i thought well it has such
simple rules one it must be easy to
program it on a computer
so i had access to a very primitive
computer a machine called the elliott
903 which had uh eight eight thousand
words of 18 bit memory so very tiny
memory but anyway the thing that i set
myself was at least to figure out
when would a piece of territory in a go
board be dead
and even that was quite hard to do i
mean you had to get to figure out what
was in closing what and i did manage to
figure that out
but um uh sort of the the more the more
elaborate versions of that i i didn't
manage to figure out and uh kind of in
part of the lesson of simple rules could
lead to complicated behavior which you
know a decade or so after that i kind of
realized big time but at that time i was
still sort of uh bashing myself against
the assumption that that wouldn't be
true and that simple rules would lead to
simple behavior but i don't really know
you know in the in the kind of very uh
publicized you know alphago tournaments
and things like this don't really know
what the
what the fundamental sort of uh core
technology that's made that work is
you know in machine learning you kind of
get to make a choice about which way in
the game tree to go and and how to
choose which way to go but it's always a
subtle thing i mean for example when
this
big jeopardy
uh ibm uh thing happened in uh
when was that that must have been 2010
or so 2009 2010 right around the time
when wolf and alfred came out because
we'd interacted with those guys at that
time
um the uh you know the question was
could you answer these general knowledge
questions
automatically
and
you know the part that was very easy to
tell i even wrote a blog post about this
was you know you feed in jeopardy
questions i think there are a couple of
hundred thousand that were available on
the web
and any old search engine would
basically get you a page of hits on the
web that contained the right answer
somewhere on that first page of results
would be and the answer is an uh a
beaver or something and that would the
word beaver would be on that front page
now the challenge was to rank those
things and say you know which one was
the actual answer it's a beaver as
opposed to a bunch of other words and
when you looked at the actual televised
you know grand match you could see in
the in the sort of runner-up answers
there were pieces of sort of disembodied
text that had been retrieved and their
capitalization wasn't even fixed um that
were the sort of runner-up answers so it
was like taking well which lump of text
would be the thing to surface and that
was the main thing but but the thing
that turned out to be
kind of the real definitive winning
aspect of it was something that had
nothing to do with the text retrieval
you know aish part of it it was instead
just the question of if you're playing
jeopardy and i'm not sure i know how to
play it you have to say i'm going to bet
on this i'm going to assume this i'm
going to i'm going to make this
following very probabilistic
quantitative bet
and the machine is just a lot better at
doing that than a human was a human had
sort of a piece of emotional baggage
that caused the human to not just use
the odds so to speak in the optimal way
and that was kind of what's what uh what
tipped the final outcome so something
very much very machine-like very not
kind of woo-hoo you know ai like um and
uh you know i think that the with chess
and go and so on and i i don't really
can't really tell you how much
is kind of uh woohoo ai like and how
much is uh it's really very much more
mechanical kinds of things of just oh
you can treat out more steps in the game
or do this or that kind of thing i do
know a chap who actually worked in my
uh research group back in the oh gosh
early 80s early to mid 80s uh was very
obsessed with teaching a computer to
play backgammon using neural networks at
that time and i never really understood
that project and i never really
understood how hard it was
or how successful or not it was but he
went on to to very much develop this
idea of
of uh reinforcement learning and so on
and learning from what you did and
figuring out sort of how to how to make
tests of what was going on um so in any
case that was uh a different um a
different direction
let's see
uh
um
the comment here
um
several comments here
uh there's a comment from philip
do i think it's regrettable that the
history of science and technology is
almost never taught political and social
history seem absurdly dominant yeah well
i don't know i haven't i haven't been in
school learning history for a well
basically half a century um
and uh so i don't really know what's
taught now but i i tend to agree that
that's that it is the social and
political history that is much more
taught perhaps almost political and
military history when i was learning
these things it's like the battle of
this happened and then this happened and
there was sort of a political forces
that led to this all that happening
i think
in um
uh you know technology has had a very
important effect on human affairs
and i think sometimes the effect is not
well codified
in the history books because
it's some
something where you know i think back in
the day when you know julius caesar was
writing about his exploits you know i
think he was writing about you know the
army won this battle he wasn't writing
oh and we had this nifty idea that um of
making a different kind of catapults and
so on that was thought to be kind of a
in in the phrase that will be used when
i was growing up in england the boffins
you know the white-coated scientists in
the back room might be making the better
catapult but that kind of wasn't part of
the the main swashbuckling flow of what
was happening that was all happening in
the front office where the people with
uh you know with the
the horses and swords and and cannons
and all those kinds of things later on
cannons um were uh were operating and i
think that was
this kind of uh this sort of
infrastructure of technology
developments i think while it is very
critical and i think that was one of the
striking things in world war ii
was that there were pieces of of clear
sort of technology
uh
you know dramatic technology events like
the uh the dropping of the first atomic
bombs and and also radar although that
was a little bit more under the radar so
to speak in terms of what was going on
but those kinds of i think maybe the uh
uh you know the the dropping of the
atomic bombs the building and dropping
the atomic bombs was was sort of a you
know this is a definitive technology
matters for for warfare kind of moment
of course in reality even in antiquity
uh people like alexander the great had
really emphasized you know having the
best technology to uh to win you know
win the sieges and so on um in in
warfare but i think it's it's um it
tends to be the case that people
emphasize you know that the technology
stuff is kind of in the background um
relative to the more obvious kind of
political forces and the redrawing of
political boundaries and things like
this
um that's uh
um
uh
yeah dan is also commenting here that
the history of science mostly focuses on
results and consequences of discoveries
instead of the background of the
characters behind them yeah that's true
and often history of science and
technology
is written in a sort of heroic form
in which there is a person individual
person who you know at some moment
figures out some amazing thing
and you know the apple falls on on isaac
newton's head and then he has a theory
of gravity
uh
in my experience no such story is the
whole story the you know there may be
some precipitating event or something
which causes people to really think
about something they weren't bothering
to think about before but usually
there's at least a decade-long kind of
run-up in which people find sort of the
context by which things work
and often there's a great entanglement
of technology and science you know you
think oh you know einstein invented
relativity and that was just a sort of
philosophical
scientific mathematical uh thing but in
fact this notion of simultaneity was
something which was always a big thing
in switzerland at the time because you
know they wanted the trains to run on
time and they had these electrical wires
telegraph wires and things going from
one station to another and it was like
could you really make sure you know that
the train was arriving at this minute
this station and you know what did that
mean in terms of simultaneity at the
next station it was really a a
technology of the time type story and
that's been true over and over again
that both in terms of the technology
that's necessary to make a discovery
microscopes telescopes electronic
amplifiers those kinds of things the uh
the the making of the discovery
is um
uh is something that um
it's it's it relies on both the
technology that allows you to make the
instruments and often the ambient way of
thinking that comes from the the fact
that that technology is all around so in
today's world the fact that we have
computers all around and we have
intuition about how computers work has
been at least for me really critical in
defining what happens in basic science i
will tell you one footnote to history
that i just learnt i mentioned josiah
willa gibbs kind of pioneer
uh yale university pioneer of um
uh of statistical mechanics in the late
seven late 1800s
um here's a here's a piece of strange
history he didn't have very many
students one of them was a guy called
leader forest
who
was a kind of an inventor
and um uh who you know in the
traditional heroic version he just sort
of invented stuff well actually he had a
physics phd and he studied a bunch of
physics and it wasn't just oh he'll just
pull these inventions out of thin air um
but one of the things he invented was
the triode the uh the
vacuum tube amplifier or switch
which was critical to early radio and
things like this or to and to electronic
amplification and i just it's an
interesting fact that he was a student
graduate student in physics of uh of
gibbs um and so there was a sort of
relationship between the statistical
mechanics and the origination of vacuum
tube technology and triodes and so on um
through that link of a slightly colorful
inventor kind of person
but yeah i think i think one of the
things that tends to happen is that
there's a the the story of how
discoveries get made is often kind of
complicated it is easier to make the
heroic version of you know this is this
is the story and and you know one thing
doesn't help
is that sometimes even the people
involved in discoveries will heroicize
them after the fact
and something which was oh well actually
i was you know working for 20 years on
this and i you know got my phd in this
and i'd studied that and i'd written
extensively about this and that
gets conflated into oh i just had this
great idea one day partly because i
think people in their own minds remember
that moment more than they remember the
long run up to it and partly just
because it makes a better story and you
know the off told story that you know
albert einstein was a a mere patent
clerk
toiling away in the burnt patent office
when he invented relativity well
footnote he got a phd in physics and the
you know the burn patterned office was
kind of the silicon valley of its day
so you know that makes it a little bit
less
kind of just
the uh you know the poor uh kind of um
un
un uh
uh unwanted
kind of uh you know garage inventor who
had no um sort of no background in
anything that isn't usually the picture
and uh uh and usually the the full
pictures are much more
much more intertwined
with the evolution of ideas and
technology of the time and so on and the
stories are interesting and i've tried
to tell some of them i have this book
idea makers which has a collection of a
bunch of these these stories that i
tried to untangle and i've untangled
some more since then but yeah the
stories are great if they're if they're
told but but they tend not to be one
sentence foot type stories um they tend
not to be just the um you know another
one like this is uh ramanujan
uh telling j.h hardy when he got when
ramon jiang got fed up with hardy saying
but how do you how did you get this
mathematical result how do you show a
proof of that when rauner jan didn't
have any proof because he was doing
essentially experimental mathematics and
he told hardy well i you know these
things come to me from the goddess so
and so in my dreams which i'm sure was
just a joke
and it was just and yet that gets
repeated with with great kind of
seriousness as kind of ramanujan's um
source of uh
of inspiration when the true answer i
think is that he was a good calculator
and could actually work out all these
decimal digits and work out all these
series expansions and so on and then
notice patterns and such like but that's
a more difficult story to tell
um
let's see
well the question from universe within
here is in the history of science have
you ever seen something really
unexpected someone pulling something out
of their hat with no prior experience
let me think about that question
you know i'm thinking of so many
examples where that's not the case you
know they mentioned the microscope well
they were lens grinders and they were
doing detailed things the invention of
um
uh
let me think about that for a second
well i mean there are things that
yeah i mean i don't know enough about
like the discovery of penicillin
by by fleming and so on you know he was
a microbiologist and yes
you know he noticed that this mold
growing on this thing inhibited the um
uh the growth of bacteria but you had to
be growing bacteria on a plate and you
know had to know what the bacteria
looked like and you know the most
difficult thing often is that you know
too much and so when you observe
something that's unexpected you just try
and ram the unexpected thing into the
stuff you already know and then conclude
that there's nothing new and you fail to
make a discovery that's a much more
common thing than that you make an
uncontextualized discovery we just say
this is an amazing thing and it doesn't
uh you know it doesn't come with any
context because usually discoveries made
with no context are are tough i mean i'm
trying to think about ones that um
you know there were ones that were
surprising hubble's discovery of the
expansion of the universe but i mean he
was looking with a telescope but specter
of stars galaxies and so it was you know
that was not a um uh you know it's kind
of like you're looking at something and
the the trick is to not ignore it
you know when um
uh when pulsars were discovered in 1968
you know the the person jocelyn bell i
guess who was sort of on duty paying
attention to the radio telescope made
the correct thing of don't ignore the
fact that it's going beep beep beep at a
you know at a fixed frequency and you
know that could easily have been oh it
must be an instrument failure of some
kind you know nothing can do that let's
just ignore it um you know that was
important to not
not come to that conclusion so i think
avoiding avoiding failing to discover
things is a more common issue and i'm
i'm really having a hard time thinking
of something where
sort of completely uncontextualized
something just
sort of was was noticed uh by somebody
who wasn't even looking anywhere near
that area i mean there are there are
certainly effects
i mean there are plenty of effects in in
biology among other places
where
uh
you know it's it's
you have to really be paying it you have
to
come up with something which
is um
uh is not
uh
you know you have to be capable of of
absorbing something which you didn't
already know and i'm afraid that's one
of the things that is is very often
missing in research science is that
ability people don't have the confidence
to see something that they didn't expect
to see
i i know for example in fluid dynamics
one of the things that i predicted was
that there's a certain repeatability to
apparently random flow patterns and
fluid dynamics and i asked a lot of
fluid experimentalists this is now 25
years ago or more
i said have you ever seen this
some of us said well now that you
mention it
yeah we kind of have seen that
but we never put it in papers because it
was so weird that nobody would have
believed it
well okay that's how you miss a big
phenomenon is it so weird that nobody
would believe it
um
and so that you know i think that's a
big challenge
uh
i think um
let's see
right as dan is commenting surprising
events when someone is an expert in
field a
somehow finds a connection with field b
and makes the discovery in field b
that's happened many many times it's
happened particularly between physics
and other fields
and you know i myself have tried to try
to push this a certain amount between a
variety of different fields but you know
it's a general it's a general thing that
when there's when one field has
developed to sort of conceptual ideas
and formalism and so on that goes a
certain distance
it's uh you know to then it's almost
like the thermodynamic case that the
thing goes from the hotter hotter area
to the colder area you're sort of moving
moving ideas from the hotter field to
the colder fields so to speak you know
one thing i was just thinking about
recently and i need to track down more
of this history when dna was when the
digital structure of dna was was
identified by
by jim watson and francis quick in um
in 1953
digital information
was a new kind of thing
there were computers the oniac 1946
things like that there were electronic
tabulating machines things like this
but this idea of things like computer
memory and the idea of digital mem
remembering digital information was very
new
and i kind of do wonder what the
relationship was
between this sort of notion of of
digital information that we now knew
could be stored in large-scale forms
and in what were then well first it was
punch cards and that was from from much
earlier but by that time it was kind of
more in digital computers
how that affected the ability to make
the discovery that there was digital
information in dna again it was one of
these things where there was a certain
contextualization from the ambient
technology situation to allow one to get
to this place where you could you could
talk about something at a purely
scientific level
the
uh
parker is commenting that feel like
einstein's thought experiments were
really up there like how
the the thing following a beam of light
and so on yeah i think you know einstein
was in some ways a philosopher
in a sense more than a traditional
physicist because traditional physicists
had really had the point of view
you know newton laid down these laws of
motion it is our job to go and work out
with calculus what the consequences of
these are and that was a very large part
of physics whether it was in fluid
dynamics or rigid body mechanics or
whatever else
and this idea of let's just
philosophically think about what must
happen if
you know thought experiment xyz
was something rather different from from
what had traditionally been done i think
by by the by the by the physicists of
the day
um it's something that kind of
methodology of the sort of the
philosophical thinking things through
thing is something i must say i've uh
taken to doing quite a lot of and we
have a very interesting kind of strange
sort of pincer situation where we have
on the one hand kind of philosophical
thinking about the things and on the
other hand computer experiments and
between those two things that's where
most of the innovations that i've been
able to make recently have come from is
kind of interweaving kind of the big
strategic philosophical points and
realizations with let's just run it on a
computer and see what happens and
develop a sort of empirical intuition
from that along with kind of conceptual
inhibition from thinking intuition from
thinking about things at a sort of
philosophical level
so i think that's um but yes that's a
this idea that you can kind of think
about things philosophically at some
level and make thought experiments and
deduce things just from sort of that
intuitive stack you have to have a
certain amount of confidence to be able
to do that because it's a lot easier to
know you've got the right answer if
you're building step by step by step
with math formulas and things then to
say i'm going to make this intuitive
jump from here to there do i get to the
right answer i mean i i must say that
for myself
i you know think i've developed a
reasonably good intuition for some
things but the way i know that i know
what i'm talking about is i do computer
experiments and often those experiments
don't agree precisely with my initial
intuition and so that means that i'm i'm
kind of
you know i have this kind of aphorism
the computational animals are smarter
than we are so to speak they always do
things we don't expect
um maybe our principle of computational
equivalence should make that aphorism
really be the computational animals are
just as smart as we are um but uh it
certainly feels like they're smarter
than us because we don't expect you know
we expect to be able to figure out
what's happening and we can't
um
so a question here from from parker or
um
uh why does that intuition even work
actually
talking of which hold on
just one second guys i will be right
back with you
oh again
i'm in a place where if i don't
have some water i will croak out totally
um
anyway that we were talking about some
intuition
and uh
the the value of intuition and whether
it's
underrated in science and why does it
even work
you know i think intuition is about
we are sort of uh connecting patterns of
things together there's something that
um uh you know we see this it's kind of
like something else we've already seen
it's kind of like it has to work this
way in a sense
typical machine learning systems
are they're pretty good on intuition
that is they're able to sort of
extrapolate from you know i think this
video is going to do this in the next
few frames that's something that's very
much a sort of intuition type story of
we've got this kind of conceptual
framework and we're fitting things into
that framework we've kind of got this
and we see this in in in machine
learning systems and so on that it's
kind of like can we fit this thing
approximately with the thing we've
already seen and that's kind of the the
story it seems for for intuition i think
that the uh the question of really it's
something one might think of it in terms
of machine learning as some kind of
encoding function the question of can
you really translate from the intuition
of physics to the intuition of biology
or something like that that's an
interesting thing another question is
each different field has a different
kind of pattern of intuition the kinds
of reasoning that work in economics are
different from the kinds of reasoning
that work in physics or in mathematics
or whatever else and i think that's
another thing that's always a challenge
for people who are kind of making the
jump from field a to field b
they both get a lot of extra power from
the intrusion of field a but they if
they land in field b
and they need the intuition of field b
that's often not such an easy thing to
get
so
let's see the question from rbs will we
ever get a philosophical programming
language
oh i hope so i mean in the following
sense
uh maybe just in terms of words
the um
uh back in the 1600s it was a big thing
to try and make philosophical languages
people you know the language of
scholarship had been latin for a couple
of thousand years
and uh uh well mostly with a
maybe a a um an arab sort of uh
diversion in the middle ages uh but but
no in large measure sort of the language
of at least one strand of scholarship
have been latin by the 1600s people were
like oh we should be writing in french
or german or english or whatever else
and so people were looking for is there
a way we can universalize knowledge
before it sort of fragments into all
these seemingly different languages and
so on and that was part of the
motivation of people like leibniz for
mathematical notation was to have an
internationalized version of the system
of describing mathematics that's worked
out really well there really is an
international mathematical notation
there's just one for our whole planet so
to speak it's not the case that you know
even in times when when for many years
the sort of the main scientific
developments of a country was separated
from the rest of the world it isn't the
case that developed its own math
notation or that's almost completely
true i mean there's there's some stuff i
suppose in the soviet union that um a
few things where the abbreviations for
trigonometric functions are slightly
different and a few bits and pieces like
that but that's minority issue really
the the bulk of it is very much the same
but at that same time in the 1600s there
was kind of this idea
that um uh
one should um
one should find a way
to um
uh
uh to describe things in the world in a
in a purely sort of philosophical form
devoid of the details of particular
human languages so there were a bunch of
developments along these lines
um
uh leibniz did some of that with his
characteristic universe solace
um there'd been a person called john
wilkins
who was a british guy
who um um let's see an essay concerning
[Music]
a the real a real character i think was
that was its title something like that
um it's a big big thick book that
attempts to define a kind of
philosophical language a language that
has kind of a symbolic representation of
things in the world
so it has it's rather charming to see
the um the kind of categories that are
relevant i mean kind of the these
thesaurus-like categories relevance at
the time there's an awful lot of stuff
about death
um much and there's an awful lot of
stuff all the different ways to die
are very much enumerated there's
stuff about you know foods and things
are very different from today there's
much less about technology um and
there's a certain amount about kind of
human affairs and there's a bunch about
theology um and in fact the the thing
that at the time it was not very clear
to people there's kind of the words the
structure of the words then there's the
way you write the words the kind of
morphology the character you use and in
the case of of wilkins's work you know
he basically did the whole stack so you
know in the end his kind of his peak
sort of demo was right
writing the lord's prayer um in
uh in his artificial language in his
philosophical language
but it's very bizarre because it's
written these weird runic characters in
addition to being written with different
words and etcetera etcetera etcetera but
that was a big push in the 1600s to
develop this kind of philosophical
language
it died after that people didn't try
again late 1800s there were a few
efforts um
esperanto was was an example in the late
1800s
that was an example of an artificial
language which would intended to be sort
of a a um
i think it was called an auxiliary
language something where sort of you
know if if people were there was a
person you know
the the lithuanian met
the person from the basque country or
something and they had no common
language you know what would they speak
well maybe they should speak esperanto
and then they'd be able to understand
each other that was kind of the idea
um the person called zaminoff polish
chap was the person who originated that
and esperanto was intended to be sort of
a simplified language that would take
its words from kind of the generic
european melting part of words and and
would have no irregular verbs and things
like this
it was somewhat successful i mean it was
um i know uh well i was i was back in
when i was a kid at heathrow airport in
london for example there was still uh
signage that was up in multiple
languages but one of those languages was
esperanto and that signage finally got
taken down maybe 20 years ago 25 years
ago it's kind of sad um but uh and you
know the total number of books in
esperanto is some number of thousands
it's not millions and it's not nothing
like the the tens of millions in english
um
but uh and there were a number of other
uh sort of um efforts to make these kind
of um
artificial languages i mean they've been
more recent ones uh the two kind of
extreme cases they're both interesting
one is it quill by john quiada
um which is some
uh
a language which attempts to be the
biggest language you can imagine
where you take kind of all of the kinds
of tense structures and
all these constructions from all the
different human languages and you meld
it together in one language that's kind
of one extreme case
where i think it's fair to say that even
the creator of a language can't really
speak the language but it's a language
which maybe if you could speak it you
would be able to express things in a
very rich way
and the the sort of alternative extreme
is a language called toki pona
by
sonja lang i think
um which is a language which attempts to
be as minimal as possible with only 300
words
and so you have to kind of
circumlocute your way to different kinds
of concepts
but this idea of of sort of having a
language that represents
everyday
kinds of discourse
uh is an interesting idea something
relevant for writing you know
computational contracts where you want
to write about the world not in legalese
but in something that computers can
understand i've been pretty interested
in this stuff kind of the phrase i've
used which i'm not wholly happy with is
symbolic discourse language to describe
this kind of thing once trying to create
i hope that it won't be very long before
we will have such a thing but we'll see
depends on all the other pieces of work
and distractions and uh and things about
running companies and so on that
that i need to do in the in the
intervening time and uh all the
different things that come in from
science
and the extent to which we have this
tremendously fertile period of sort of
scientific um uh investigation right now
well let's see
uh
we probably have to wrap up a moment
here
um
but maybe one or two
more hmm
it's a question here interesting from
john
um
what do you think about the relationship
of philosophical thinking and
experimental mathematics
the limits of reasoning the limits of
turing machines
huh
well
um
you know i think
that
philosophy
is kind of a
a getting a bigger picture of the way
things are
and whether those things are things
about sort of the human world or things
about the natural world or things about
the mathematical world
it's kind of zooming out and getting
bigger pictures and making deductions
that are not
deductions for the specifics of those
particular areas but general deductions
about things of that kind
and i think that experimental
mathematics is another source
of it's a sort of another world about
which you can have sort of philosophical
thoughts
uh and i think
the um
uh the thing that um
uh you know if we look back to the you
know oldest kinds of philosophical
traditions
you know people like aristotle
were sort of trying to describe things
in the world
and huma and bring them to a human level
you know why does something fall to the
center of the earth because it has a you
know it it sort of wants to do that so
that's sort of a humanization of that
idea
and i think a lot of what um you know a
lot of what the sort of the science ends
up being at that time and and it was
then considered to be natural philosophy
was to take what we observe in the world
and try and sort of connect it to human
ways of thinking about things now
sort of a different branch was the
development of logic where aristotle was
taking kind of the arguments that humans
make that seem to just follow one from
another in a sort of necessary way and
making kind of a
a formal structure that was independent
of the particulars of the arguments that
were being made whether it was about
going to war or whether it was going to
rain tomorrow
and being able to make statements about
p and q he didn't call them p and q yet
but um being able to make statements
based on the on the structure the
syllogistic structure the syllogisms of
things you know
uh
uh all men immortal socrates is a man
therefore socrates is mortal it doesn't
have to be you know it's um uh you know
uh let's see
um
uh you know
uh a salmon is a fish fishes swim
therefore salmon swim
um
the uh um you know that that's the
structure of that thing and you can feed
in all these different kinds of of uh
particulars and still have the same
structure but i think i think that's um
that's the way i would view it now
the question of
of kind of the
the limits of what we can think about
versus the limits of what we can
uh have computation do
well you know in my in our sort of
theory of physics
in the end our universe is computational
all the way down so in the end what we
can do in our universe is what can be
done with computation but it's a
slightly some more subtle story because
what we can sense
what we can take out of our universe
with the senses that we have with the
computational boundedness of us as human
observers
that's a much different set of things we
don't get to go down and look at the
atoms of space and look at the full
structure of the ruliad of all possible
computations
we are stuck sampling a tiny piece of
the ruling ad in a computationally
bounded kind of way and at that level we
observe certain things about the
universe and it's not the whole story in
some sense it's the whole story is a
story that is almost an unstory because
it's the story that is a necessary story
it's a story that has no particulars in
it it's the story that is sort of all
framework and nothing else but
everything is ultimately just a piece of
that of that whole framework
and so i think the uh you know when we
talk about sort of the limits of
computation
the the ultimate computation i was done
by the universe is has a certain
structure that's all about sort of that
can be thought of in terms of turing
machines that's not a particularly
fertile way to think about it but you
could in principle think about it that
way you're going to principal convert
the actual computations the universe
does to their equivalent turing machine
computations so that's one sort of level
the other level is what can us humans
take out of that
and another question is
what uh and so i think the answer here
is that the parts of the universe that
are of any interest to us because
they're parts that are we're sensitive
to are just the parts that we get to
extract so it's not quite the case
that so the parts that are that are
accessible to us humans and about which
we can have what you might describe as
philosophical thinking rather than
computational grinding those parts
are you might say well they're only a
small part because that's just the stuff
we humans could deal with but actually
that's the only part that we humans sort
of care about out of this whole sort of
mass of possibilities that exists in the
rouliad
so i mean now footnote to all of that is
the fact that the ruliad is this
entangled limit of all possible
computations
is a definite statement it could be
hyper computations when we have a turing
machine simple model of computation and
we say let's run the turing machine for
a really long time okay let's ask the
question what would the turing machine
do after an infinite time the halting
problem what does it eventually hold so
will it keep going forever that's not a
question that we can in general answer
in finite time we can't convert what
would take a turing machine infinite
time to something we can answer in
finite night time but we can always
imagine that we have an oracle for a
turing machine where it just is set up
to be the case that you just ask it does
this turning machine halt or not just
says yes or no we don't say how it works
we don't build it out of turing machines
but it's just a thing that exists
so if we believe such things exist
then we are talking not about the ruliad
of all possible sort of turing machine
level computations but about the hyper
ruliad which is kind of a thing that
contains these hyper computations
i don't think that i think the one fact
that is a contingent fact about our
world is that we live in the rouliad and
not in the ruling ad
but it sort of doesn't make much
difference because
from the ruliad there is an event
horizon we we don't get to to have
causal effects from either from the
ruliad to the hyper ruliad or from the
hi or from the hyper ruling ad to the
ruliad these two things are separated in
actually very much the same way that a
black hole might be separated by its
event horizon uh from from the rest of
the universe and what's happening in
there you know the fate of the
civilization that got crushed with the
star that made this black hole is
something quite separate and independent
and invisible to the outside part of the
part of the universe and so it is with
the hyper roulette versus the roulette
so
um
yeah well let's see i i think um
there's a question here from universal
comment about the in the
multi-computational paradigm which areas
am i most excited to redefine the
history of
uh saying i'm excited to see redefine
the history of natural selection well
interesting i might uh actually be
having a conversation about that with
somebody just today we shall see
um
all right and let me just see if there's
one more question i can try and address
for this time
and then we should wrap it up for now
um
let's see
building
future has uh made the comment it seems
that in the history of science and
technology that the hard research is
usually kept out of the public eye
has it been beneficial or overwhelming
having uh our work open to the public
live streamed and so on
uh
it's been interesting it's been great
actually
it's been
it's really made it all more fun
and i hope been
useful for the world
um
why is most research
sort of done behind closed doors
it's partly because people think that
it's so technical nobody would
understand
but also
it's partly for
i would say
uh reasons like
the actual doing of research involves
many mistakes being made and people
don't have the confidence to be out
there in public
making mistakes
that's it one thing another thing is
many areas of research are deeply
competitive and people are like i
wouldn't want to put that out there
because my competitor would get it
instead
and um so that's i think those are the
those are kind of some of the some of
the driving forces there
and um
i think you know for for me
my ability my efforts to sort of explain
things in a way that uh uh is even worth
live streaming because it's not so
unbelievably you know drowning in
technicality and so on and drowning in
detail
even the effort to get things to the
point where it is not absurd to do that
is a worthwhile effort in helping me to
understand sort of how things how things
work better so that's been a win it's
also been terrific to have people
actually make suggestions and comments
in real time that's very very helpful
it's i would say
much more helpful than um uh you know
you write a paper you send it into an
academic journal and and somebody says
oh you didn't uh reference my works
enough and so except they won't say my
works because it's all supposed to be
anonymous which is a very big big
mistake but that's a different issue and
um and it also bounces around in that
way it's much better to have something
where somebody says on some live stream
we're doing uh wait a minute guys you
know have you thought about this or that
that's a much more effective kind of uh
you know review loop
than than something long after the fact
you wrote the thing and then somebody is
sort of complaining about something
where they didn't really understand what
you were talking about either um and uh
so yes i think it's been um
you know i've done it in different ways
you know when i spent a decade in the
1990s writing my big book a new kind of
science
i did find it rather overwhelming to
interact with people at the beginning of
that because i just got so many
questions asked and people were always
asking these questions and i was like oh
well i should investigate that and then
i realized that if i were to investigate
all these things i would just i would
never be able to make sort of progress
on them on the actual project that i
wanted to do so i kind of closed down
and started just doing my project and
not interacting with the outside world
but i would say that had live streaming
been a thing at the time it would have
been great it would have been really i
think i probably would have gotten that
project finished maybe four years
earlier than i did if i'd had the
opportunity to kind of have the they had
the forcing function of explaining
myself and had kind of the uh the kind
of um
uh the infused the the the the um sort
of extra energy from kind of sharing it
with people in the outside world that
would have been a very energizing kind
of thing it is an interesting question i
i know i get inquiries from time to time
from academics and so on saying you know
how can we live stream our our stuff too
and it's like the basic answer is well
it's technically very easy and you know
the main issue is you just have to be
confident enough to realize that you're
going to do this it's going to be
completely unscripted and what's going
to happen is going to happen and you
know yes they're going to be things that
get messed up they're going to be things
where you follow some direction and you
realize after half an hour of talking
about it it's all nonsense these things
are going to happen
and uh it's something where you know if
you take the point of view that that uh
you're not trying to show off you're
just trying to share things with people
then it's kind of it's kind of a good
thing and it it uh you know it's it's
but but i think for many people many
scientists and so on the idea that you
think in public
is is a very bizarre idea
and it's one that um i suppose you know
i've kind of developed into that idea
because i've been ceoing a company for
35 years now and uh my approach to that
involves a lot of kind of thinking in
public because i found that a very good
way to kind of get input from different
different people and also to have people
kind of understand and buy into
decisions that get made because they
were there and they could see what
happened and they could see why that was
a decision was made it doesn't just seem
like this thing that's coming from on
high or whatever else we should do this
it's like they they understood what the
what the thinking that was behind that
decision actually was
all right well we should wrap up here
for today
and
i look forward to being with you again
um
i think i will be doing a
science and technology q a for kids and
others on friday although it might be in
a slightly even more exotic location
um and
otherwise we'll be back um
uh next week and i think we have for
some other
uh kinds of day job um
uh software design and um
other live ceo and kinds of um
live streams coming up
so well thanks for joining me and see
you another time
bye for now